oh my God it's so pretty
he put a ring on it
you know Kim has been waiting to say
that
[Music]
he put a ring on it
talk about determination Usman proposes
to Kim after he receives his mom's
blessing yes
but you know there's always a butt in 90
Day land after the proposal Kim and
Usman speak with an immigration attorney
who informed them that what they agreed
to in usman's Mom's contract Kimberly
Marcella who's been to marry a young
lady in the future to enabled to have
children it's illegal
you can not be for real I mean at what
point do you just stop and say maybe
this just is not meant to be seriously
let's get into it
[Music]
okay 90 day fans fam it's malicium
before we get into the recap I just want
to take a moment to wish a Happy
Thanksgiving to those of you who
celebrate enjoy the food my favorite
part enjoy your loved ones that's good
too and if you're not doing anything
major take some time to enjoy yourself
all right let's go ahead and get into a
few other musty moments before we get
into Usman and Kim first up Bilal and
shaida and her bestie utris
but I don't think we should be so
presumptuous last episode below and
uterus did the most over dinner in New
York City they got into this heated back
and forth because uterus wanted to ask
whatever she wanted in regards to below
and shot his relationship
and Below straight up told her she was
being oh nosy which didn't sit too well
with uterus I'm trying to come close
myself just give me a second it's very
serious so
yeah when it comes to the argument I
read a number of your takes and I love
how some of your perspectives just
opened my mind up to things I didn't
even think about you know two cute
puppies that's quote whether below is
right or not she is shaida's best friend
and will be the first person she runs to
for support when she's having
relationship issues after that
conversation what does he think her best
friend will say and do next time Shada
needs her friend she's gonna bad mouth
allow and encourage Shadow to leave him
sometimes being right is irrelevant
because you've got a lot to lose beware
of your words below I agree two cute
puppies pick your battles wisely I think
that speaks to what a lot of you
mentioned when you said that Bilal
finally met his match with uterus I also
saw that a lot of you feel as if Bilal
should have brought that same YouTube
nosy energy with his ex-wife shahida and
while I agree that Bilal should have
stronger boundaries when it comes to his
ex I also think it's a little different
because shahida is the mother of his
kids so as a father he's going to
approach the situation differently than
he would with his wife's best friend who
he just met as I see it that's only
natural I assume that when your kids are
in the picture there's so much more you
think about oh another take that I found
interesting was from olcz i7 it's pretty
long so I'm going to read the parts that
stood out to me and I'm going to call
you oh oh says in part quote I get she
utris wanted to be protective but as a
friend she should keep it cool with
below for shy to sake Shadow chose this
man at the end of the day and wants them
to get along so she should respect that
and at least give Bilal a chance before
getting all negative you're talking a
little about you I'm sure hopefully good
things
you see what up
all girls want to say quote healthy
boundaries are important in all
relationships including friendships
besides Bilal is already shaida's
husband it's not like shot is going to
divorce him because her friend does not
approve of him see that's my thing no
matter how uterus feels about below no
matter how we feel about Bilal I'm not
getting the gist that Shada is about to
leave him at least not right now
divorces have a good option for a Muslim
I'm not saying I would have done it
perfectly if I was in uterus issues but
how I see it from the outside looking in
they're already married so as her friend
I will be thinking about ways I can make
this better and not worse and that takes
being tactful and not being led by your
emotions truly asking yourself how can I
be part of the solution here and not add
to the problem also I just want to say
shout out to all of you who are brave
enough to share your perspectives we're
not going to agree on everything we all
have different opinions and that's fine
it makes for a great conversation when
it's done with respect Plus at the end
of the day this show is for our
entertainment these are not our lives so
I think it's wise to not get too overly
invested
just throwing that out there alright
diving into this week's episode shaida
and uterus meet up the morning after her
confrontation with Bilal
last night I was glad that uterus was
sticking up for me Trish you called it
Trish James says quote a part of me
feels like Shadow knew this Clash would
happen and deep down she couldn't wait
for her best friend to tear us up
Trish I don't even know you but I could
hear you saying that
last night I was glad that uterus was
sticking up for me
but I woke up this morning and I
realized that it's not helping matters
to antagonize Bilal because that's not
the way to get him to give me what I
want and what I want right now is to
open a yoga studio and be a mother and
start a family with Bilal
hmm I'm not sure if shaida is thinking
that all the way through she says right
now she wants to start a business and
have a baby that's a lot of pressure I
mean more power to you girl if that's
what you want to do it's not impossible
but it sounds like a lot what most
people do is take off from work when
they have a new baby
hmm anyway I'm gonna apologize first
right once uterus and shaida start to
talk about the argument uterus
apologizes to shaida for making her feel
uncomfortable I feel like initially
you were a little feisty and heated
Bailey girl
yes
flashback so I can ask you anything I
sit down with her father I sit down with
her mother
all of her sisters but you didn't sit
down with me yeah best friend
I'm a Caribbean woman I understand that
that's how we are but I realize that
American culture they will take that as
something that's offensive
because if he swing the whole thing as
if it was my fault you know what I mean
and I was just like thinking is he
always like that does he do that with
you sometimes
and the crowd says
yup I
yeah it's been a kind of tricky question
here Gail
[Music]
um
like even if we him and I have an
argument if you like it's hard for me to
get my point across because I felt like
he um
he deflects a lot this is what I mean
hon
and that's what I picked up on last
night even though he just was so heated
last night Halal can be difficult to
deal with
after dinner Bella was angry so we went
to bed and there was no conversation
that's not a big surprise unfortunately
shaida then reveals something to you
Tris that leaves her speechless when I
told you we put a timeline when we could
have children and how do you feel about
that well went to the doctor the doctor
told me by the time I'm 40
there's going to be a five percent
chance to get pregnant
are you serious and what did below say
about this
since the doctor's visit Bilal and I we
have never had a conversation of when
are we going to have children now it's
kind of be three years from now when my
chances are five percent right
you can't have the competition because
it's hard for you to get through to him
yes
[Music]
shida is really in a tricky and unfair
position right now
after receiving drastic news like that
they haven't talked about it
just think about that
it comes off as a lack of respect
you need to disarm him what I mean is
make him not be so comfortable on he's
very comfortable that's why you can't
get through to him utris goes on to tell
Shada she needs to put more pressure on
Bilal when it comes to the baby I think
you've waited all these years and I mean
he deserves to understand that and to
give you everything every time I blink
my eyes I hear Tick Tock I feel as if I
continue to win
I could wait for a lifetime
later in the episode when the uterus
symbol allowed meet one-on-one for the
first time since they're back and forth
they give each other a pleasant yet
seemingly phony greeting how are you
doing you enjoying this beautiful
weather yes isn't it gonna sound pretty
nice it's nice it's a beautiful setting
and once they end the small talk you
twist Cuts straight to the chase there
was like a couple of questions that
wanted a little bit more clarissian if
that's okay with you one of the
questions uterus asked below is how he
would feel if shaida turns up pregnant
six months from now like no stretch of
the imagination or we're trying to have
children but if it was a situation where
she's like hey she's practiced I'm
pregnant you know six seven months from
now whatever great
alhamdulillah I'll praise be to God so
they're not planning to have the baby
but if the baby happens it's the will of
God
oh
you're thinking tomorrow when I speak
Australia tell her she could forget to
take her birth control pills
that way she could get pregnant
and Below say he'll be happy and I know
definitely Shadow be happy
problem solved she's coming in with that
save the day energy problem solved
we'll have to wait and see how Shadow
feels about uterus's plan although I'm
not sure if she's still taking birth
control because she mentioned this at
the beginning of their trip to New York
I'm hoping that when I leave this trip
inshallah that I'm pregnant like I hope
that we I could have some news like the
doctor told us to try so we could at
least see if something happens you know
in the meantime Ashley J says quote I
want Shadow to play a prank on Bilal and
pretend to be pregnant then he would
have to confess that he has had a
vasectomy and there ain't no way
that's hilarious well according to Bilal
he has not had one I actually asked him
about it and here's what he had to say
well there are some fans who think you
secretly sniffed yourself
heard it too I've heard it here's the
funny thing is that um one I'm black I'm
African-American uh
it's hard enough to get an
African-American male to go to a doctor
so
sniffing his Manhattan unfortunate true
we don't we typically don't do that uh
let them know I'm Muslim too so the
rumors and stuff are pretty funny yeah
all right that took longer than expected
but we had to finish that conversation
moving on I want to take a look quickly
at this next must-see moment Angela and
Michael finally go to therapy y'all well
oh thank God yes Michael suggests that
they go talk to a therapist before
Angela goes back to the states and the
therapist was pretty insightful she even
put Angela in her place in the last few
months at one point you know I was so
uh let's say frustrated I was just so
tired of everything like I mean we've
been waiting for the past two years so
you check it out why let me finish
and I'd like to just encourage you that
um when one person is speaking listen to
the other person
look at Angela's face yes let that soak
in she needs to hear that if you don't
communicate mistrust was typing so they
should relent to express themselves
without having a reservation there
should be no secret between them that's
not that's a good thing in marriage
since during the session Angela
Angel decided to confess something yeah
I do have something to tell you since
we're gonna start this like clean
I'm listening
so
I had put you ever heard of tick tock
I would love to know what this lady is
thinking I find it so interesting to see
how outside professionals who appear on
the show react to the 90 day cast
members and all of their drama at least
we know how Wild the cast in their
situations can be but in most cases I
would assume that these professionals
are learning for the first time on
camera so what is it
this thing about Billy
are you falling in love with him or what
did you develop a question I can't talk
crash there wasn't nothing big because
she's close if Michael would have said
that Angela would have flipped that room
upside down in her American Apparel
Michael says she looks like she's
running for Miss USA
are you going for Miss USA
I am Miss USA Baby okay back to the
therapy sesh I decided to tell Michael
about me having my Tick Tock crush on
Billy wait what her Tick Tock Rush
Angela is out here sounding like a gen
Zer I decided to tell Michael about me
having my Tick Tock crush on Billy
because we're both going to continue to
move forward we both need to come clean
well next week Angela's gonna go as far
as calling Billy in front of Michael hi
Billy hey Angel who do you keep talking
to my husband Michael
and then a change of pace Michael is
going to be the one who storms off
um
all right well let's move on to Kim
getting that ring last episode Usman and
Kim received his mom's blessing to get
married but they had to sign a contract
promising usman's family that Kim would
allow Usman to travel from the U.S to
Nigeria four times a year and promising
them that Kim would allow Usman to marry
a second wife so he can have children so
now that all of that is out the way and
Kim can officially be the first wife
Usman sets up this sweet proposal which
takes Kim by surprise
I like this room
what are you doing
what are you doing
[Music]
big
I told you like after all I've been
through
Tanzania Nigeria now we're here in
Nigeria with the battling struggling
my mom said yes if truly I love you what
else
sweaty now though
yes Kim is beyond happy which is nice to
see because she deserves it we all do
and one thing is for sure Kim's a
fighter she wanted this man and she did
not give up y'all remember when he would
call her potential and he wouldn't have
sex with her now they're an Engaged
couple
he put a ring on it
if I didn't partially still believe that
Usman was using her for a green card I
would say their journey is somewhat
motivational oh my God I could kiss you
here now huh
not really
[Music]
Usman and Kim reveal that the plan is
for Kim to go back to the U.S file for
the K-1 Visa once that gets approved
Usman will come to the states and they
will get married here it's not actually
that I am trying to like live in this
state here in Nigeria is where I run my
business music is there do I take care
of my family's day the ultimate goal is
that we should just have access to both
countries
I really hope Usman is genuine and he
proves us wrong because after that
statement right there all I could think
is he just wants international access
which makes sense to why he would want
someone so loyal so they can be loyal
enough until he gets his green card okay
I'm not trying to assassinate this man's
character all I'm saying is that I
personally still have doubts
and I got the blessing it's the night
before Kim leaves to go back home to
America and they call the immigration
lawyer to see what are the next steps
they should take and what she says puts
a stop
to all of their plans Camila
um my family they want me to be coming
to Nigeria every three or four months
back to Nigeria here so is that possible
and how can we go about that
that's not going to be possible
and then after the 90 days 10 years from
if you would file your application for
your green card and you're not going to
be able to travel unless you get
permission to travel
I don't want to have any problem with my
father no I don't either well when it
comes to the big stipulation here which
is that Kim must allow Usman to marry a
second wife
that's not gonna work either
engagement agreement
the lawyer said a wow
I told you watching these professionals
is something else Kimberly Marcella
who's been to marry a young lady in the
future to enable to have children look
we had to sign it well
there's a law against polygamy
I don't know if you guys know that
so in other words in the United States
you can't can't marry more than one
woman
but not in the United States but if he
went if he comes back to Nigeria and
picks a woman from his
region then he could do it here it just
wouldn't be recognized in the United
States right even though it's okay to do
an
office in the United States is
prohibited and so
um you would could lose your greeting
card if it were found that you weren't
polygamous that you married were married
more to more than one person
dang another roadblock and this time
it's the government not his mama it's
going to be interesting to see how they
get through this one fast forward the
episode ends with Usman dropping Kim off
at the airport and an emotional goodbye
I only have like so like short limited
times with him you know
so it's just hard like I wish I could
just take him with me or just stay
longer or something
I love you I love you too babe I'll text
you when I get to Germany okay
all right bye
[Music]
this trip showed me how much I mean to
Usman but it is really discouraging that
our marriage could be in danger
I feel like so much of our future is
just out of our control well when it
comes to next week's preview it looks as
if Kim and Usman aren't going to give up
their marriage plans just yet apparently
usman's gonna look into adoption
everything was so confusing with the
lawyer so we need to talk about like how
we want things done we found out that
taking a second wife is illegal in
America but it's really important too
that he has a child I feel like maybe
I'm going to adopt what I don't
understand who the craziness is a child
me I'm asking do you want to raise him
no no Kim that is another huge
compromise
oh all right 90 day fans fam we're gonna
have to wait and see how she responds to
that but in the meantime next week there
will not be a recap but I'll be back the
following week with everything you need
to know see you next time
[Music]